(cri de ralliement)
Le cri de ralliement de ces
soldats de l'US Navy raisonne
dans la capitale américaine,
comme des encouragements
pour ces combattantes
ukrainiennes qui ont
momentanément quitté le front.
Elles ont cinq jours pour
convaincre des décideurs
américains de leur donner
plus d'armes. Car celles déjà
reçues ont fait toute la
différence lors de la dernière
contre-offensive.
Quand les lance-missiles Himar
a a a apparus sur le champ
de bataille, ils ont durement
frappé les positions russes,
jusqu'à atteindre et détruire
leurs dépôts de munitions.
Ivanna, médecin de famille
convertie en médecin chef d'un
bataillon, est venue témoigner
des exactions russes qu'elle a
pu voir de ses propres yeux.
Elle a vu des signes de crimes
de guerre. Le plus horrible pour
elle c'est de voir des enfants
victimes d'armes interdites.
ililililisent des bombes à
fragmentation et des bombes
au phosphore.
La sergente Adrianna Arekhta
opere des chars d'assaut. C'est
une spécialiste du déminage.
Depuis l'annexion de la Crimée
en 2014, elle a libéré
pas moins de sept villes.
Et nous rencontrons, pour
la première fois en personne,
Yaryna. Aide soignante,
opératrice de drones de
reconnaissance, elle noutttt
donné quelques entrevues
depuis le front du Donbass.
"Nous avons besoin de chars,
car l'Ukraine est occupée
par des chars et elle doit être
libérée par des chars."LaLaLaLan
partielle décrétée par Vladimir
Poutine n'inquiète pas
ces combattantes outre-mesure.
Pour Daria, ce geste trahit
le désespoir de Poutine.
Mais elle admet que 300 000
soldats, c'est une grande forc
Ivanna ajoute que les Russes
n'ont aucune motivation
parce qu'ils ne défendent pas
leur pays.
Elles sont arrivées avec une
liste détaillée de leurs besoins
militaires fournie par leur
commandement.
"Ce qu'elles veulent, c'est
ne plus découvrir de charniers.
Car même si le mot génocide
semble difficile à admettre
ailleurs, en Ukraine, c'est
la malheureuse réalité",
affrime Yaryna.
"Ce n'est pas juste de
l'armement, mais il s'agit de
protéger des vies et de leur
permettre de survivre à l'hiver.
e e e e artillerie est faible
devant celle des Russes.
Le potentiel de guerre de
la Russie est vraiment énorme."
Quinze minutes : c'est le temps
dont elles disposent pour
convaincre chaque sénateur
qu'elles vont rencontrer.
Le  séjour est organisé par
l'International Republican
Institute, qui en est à
sa sixième mission de lobbying
en faveur de l'U....
Un Institut proche du parti
républicain et financé par
le gouvernement fédéral.
"Les retours sont encourageants
avec un large soutien bipartisan
pour plus d'assistance à
l'Ukraine. Ces dames fournissent
des informations à jour, dit-il,
Elles sont des témoins directes
sur cee e e e passe."
Des décideurs à l'écoute,
mais qui  doivent eux-mêmes
tenir compte de l'opinion
de leurs électeurs.
Obtenir la paix et la sécurité,
en s'armant davantage.
Yaryna est reconnaissante envers
son président et à la communauté
internationale pour ne pas avoir
accepté des négociations
impossibles avec la Russie.
Il faut les sortir par la force
et non avec des accords de paix.
Les négociations ne seront
possibles que si la Russie
devenait une démocratie.
Déterminées, prêtes à défendre
atatatation jusqu'au bout.
"On pleurera nos morts après
la victoire." Ici Ici Ici Ici Y,
Radio-Canada, Washington.